[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANA PATRICIA ESQUEDA: Nobody
in my family,
or at least the generation
before me, has gone to college.
So even within my generation,
I'm the first one.
The hardest part of
being first-generation
is that you, at
least at home, don't
have anyone who's guiding you.
So my mom didn't know what a
personal statement was, or she
didn't know how to
apply to financial aid.
She didn't even
realize that we had
to have records of our
taxes to submit every year.
So it's the little things
where you take them for granted
before you're
applying to college.
But then when you're
applying, and it's so hard
to even explain to your family.
And then with me, there
was the language barrier.
NIMISHA BARTON:
Ana Patricia began
with the Princeton University
Preparatory Program, also known
as PUPP,
a selective college
prep program that
helps first-gen, low-income
students in the area
get into highly selective
college programs.
And then of course, FSI,
Freshman Scholars Institute,
which is a summer
academic bridge program.
And then finally, the Scholars
Institute Fellows Program
kind of allows us to continue
to provide mentorship
to these students, to remain
in close touch with them,
primarily through the workshops.
Some of the roundtables, some
of the panels that we offer,
that's meant to kind of
help them navigate what it's
like to be a student
at Princeton in terms
of the academic skills
you have to have,
and in terms of, just sort of
like, mental health and life
skills kind of support.
ANA PATRICIA ESQUEDA:
SIFP has also helped
in terms of building
or maintaining
that community of low-income
or first-generation students
who are kind of going through
the same thing at once,
and who can help one another in
terms of how to pick a major,
how to balance
your workload, how
to find internships --
things that,
to someone who is coming as
a first-generation college
student, you kind of
need that guidance.
NIMISHA BARTON: It's extremely
important for Princeton
to continue its policies
around college access,
and also to continue in the
vein that it already has begun --
creating these programs,
these continuing
support programs for students.
These four-year programs,
I think, ultimately
render visible all things that
all students need to succeed.
ANA PATRICIA ESQUEDA: I don't know
exactly how I got interested
in psychology.
But I know what I want to do --
criminal psychology, which
would be working with inmates.
Our criminal justice
system doesn't really
do justice to the inmates
that are in the prison system.
And then back to my upbringing,
the criminal justice system
of Venezuela is even more
messed up in its ways.
So I think having
a way to impact
the lives of those inmates,
and having a way of finding out
why they're doing the crimes
that they're committing,
and how we can stop that before
it even gets to that point.
NIMISHA BARTON: I hope
that Ana Patricia finds
independent projects with
faculty advisers and mentors
here that are really
meaningful and exciting to her.
She just has so much to
offer, and so much potential.